[Music]
in life lessons news submitted by League
ma like my my but I think it's lick my
balls
that's it becoming the new like Haram
bathing like ah shut the [ __ ] up or
anyway the gorillas like anything you
posts are AP Jaramillo your dicks out
for rambha oh that yeah lick my balls I
say just like when ultraviolet what like
a bunch of websites said that the like
the biggest twitch guy ever died from
Lima and it was like just like fake news
forever that's funny
a writer suggests a seven changes to
make in your life if you always think
the grass is greener oh if you're always
like like Tupac must be nice you're
always like oh that must be nice fall
balls greener where you water at [ __ ] I
don't think I had that issue that's
actually one of the things I wrote there
you know what it is grass is greener
yeah when you envy other people's lives
and possessions and things and all that
stuff yes wiener wherever Bart is
because you probably shits on the ground
and it fertilizes it or you just always
want what you don't have even even even
if it's not better she just made a fart
joke and you didn't listen to it I heard
it Judy [ __ ] on some grass you [ __ ] on
some grass first great grass or a prize
in the backyard and those fruits are
really good they're pretty sweet you did
not yeah he Deanna two hundred dollars
last me oh you know do you think I don't
live the Native American Way no I do I
give back to the earthly by [ __ ] on
it pee-yew you guys have all had
Pittsburgh great they were I think you
try them - yeah you ate it - Croatoan
don't judge him it's alright
you just had him this morning oranges I
knew it yes it was writers they're
making suggestions it's like you know
how to change your perspective so you
don't always have to be like the grass
is always greener so number one is leave
your jealousy at the front door so
jealousy is
your biggest obstacle standing in your
own way and it all it does it's it's
putting tensions on a lot of your
relationships when you see like people
in your lives and you're envious of them
if you can't be happy for them for
whatever is happening good in their
lives because you're always thinking
like well I wish that wasn't me the
easier said than done girl jealousy is a
dick thing that [ __ ] it's like candy you
go in and you're just like [ __ ] [ __ ]
I wish I had Barry mop you can you [ __ ]
no you look fancy though yeah yeah
usually comes from food though just yeah
you ever walk into a [ __ ] restaurant
and you look at people's plates in your
life got the wrong thing I wish I had
that I wish I had that too but that's a
pretty easy song bro yeah you just
ordered that it's a restaurant do you
sit down and you order your stuff and
then you like it but you start looking
over life there you go I think your
issues do you have to think I could
solve them I'm being jealous it's just
fun being jealous it's fun on the screen
yeah it is like I know I feel like
jealous people know what the [ __ ] they
got to do you know to me like it's like
it's like you see someone that looks
good especially people that transform
you know what I mean like like I really
look up to big like women that actually
became really freaking like fit what
about men nah it's women it's always
women men are crazy you know why yeah
for women I don't care if a guy gets fit
when a girl gets fit she looks hot and
it's eye candy
so it's for me actually she did it for
you yeah it was like good job you don't
know but at the same time there's a lot
of people that hate on that because it's
like oh you used to be like you I used
to be able to look at you and then think
oh at least I'm not as fat as you when
they when they surpass you than in it it
don't forces you to go oh [ __ ] now I
gotta change and people don't like that
there are some people who are also like
that's really good you're you don't like
your body you're saying you didn't like
it and you're fat so what you're saying
that you don't like fat people like you
can't you don't like people like me
that's why cuz it challenge
them to go oh [ __ ] I should be going to
the gym too and then it makes them feel
like they got to do something with life
but then they want to stay complacent
they want to stay where they are and
feel okay about it they want everyone's
grass to be brown mm-hmm but not poop
around Anna everyone does not brown
grass like mine reminds me there's this
girl on my facebook that her and her
boyfriend seemed so great together
traveling the world designer [ __ ]
whatever everything was like damn dude
that must be so nice as when I was like
younger I'd am ish it's so nice and then
in the middle of night one night she
posted a status I guess and then it was
a consumer you please help me my
boyfriend always gets drunk and beats me
yeah yeah social media makes this green
some be different again nice [ __ ] for
all the idiots we need so you know I
have the the regretful flu the [ __ ]
when I did the regretful flu we need
something for Bart we need to put a
disclaimer we need it to flamer so
people know like that's a joke guys or
just like a little things disclaimer
he's joking you dumb [ __ ]
it's what to get beat if we to get nice
[ __ ] disclaimer he's joking you dumb
[ __ ] haha alright number two stop
saying you'll do it one day so like you
know people that are saying the grass is
always greener they're always saying
like well one day I'm gonna do this one
day I'm gonna do that and they never do
it that guy starts mundo oh they never
do it oh no you do that yeah are you
grass is greener
I actually am but nothing jealousy part
I don't get jealous yeah I think envious
you said unless you man I think jelly a
jealousy and envy and aggresses is
greener is different like it can be but
they're not well I think I think what
they're trying to say is there's many
ways to have the grass is greener
mentality number one was the joke though
number one is like [ __ ] they'll call
greenish [ __ ] is you know that's kind of
Jose yeah yeah yeah and that the second
one is like all water at one
one issue you have staring at their
grass to work on your own yeah I don't
disagree with the one day mentality
because sometimes it could be motivating
because like one day one day I'm gonna
get a farm yeah one day you know or
there's orders like one day and then you
don't do nothing
yeah don't do nothing
there's no they're saying like it's fine
to have dreams and stuff but like are
you focusing on getting to your dreams
today yeah what are you doing today
right now yeah a lot of people like work
a normal job like oh yeah one day I'll
probably try YouTube or one day I'll
prep my own business that that's like
90% of people know everybody one of the
realest things I ever heard was goals
without plans or wishes yeah yeah so
when your plan should be like literally
tomorrow I'm doing this or the next hour
I'm doing this well they're not goals or
just I wish I always said one day I'm
gonna win the lottery but I never bought
tickets today's gonna be the day mm-hmm
one day I'll buy tickets next one number
three make a conversation as much as
possible so the more you talk to people
the more you'll realize that the grass
is really the same shade for you as well
as other boyfriend chunk boyfriend yeah
drunk boyfriend girl yeah everyone got
she grabbed her ass beep I always think
that everybody's life is way more [ __ ]
up than mine oh good you're like my
grass is greener than everyone everyone
got brown grass like I got my [ __ ]
together some people [ __ ] yup hey
alright so next one number four embrace
a curious mind so curious curiosity is
everything when you think the grass is
greener on the other side it starts a
conversation and then it moves into
actions reactions and creating something
for yourself what that's why you kind of
bless it I got us some about dreams and
then not action being not a goal or some
[ __ ] I don't know he said something
super motivational I'll always do that
yeah without a plan our wishes this is a
this is just be curious know these are
seven chained oh wait you're time this
one the curious one
says curiosity okay pretty much right
now
like if you're thinking of the if you're
thinking the grass is always greener
you're stuck in one mindset but if
you're challenging your thoughts are you
try to be creative
oh I'm curious I mean like snap out of
it yeah I could sum this all in one okay
one thing people who think the grass is
greener feel that they have no control
over their own actions or decisions yeah
and that's I think 90 people - mm-hmm
yeah that's why I like one of the things
that they wrote here is ask questions
tend to your own grass or plant new
seeds that you think may be even better
yeah you know I'm gonna bring my grass
out and put in fig sauce but not always
green that she's green as [ __ ] I'll just
spray-paint when it runs out but most
people can't even control your own mind
I think that's the hardest thing is is
there's no self-awareness there's no
understanding that like their actions
can create some type of result or
anything like that it's always at the
whim of the world or something you know
it's so that's why there's this must be
nice mentality it's like oh you're so
lucky you're so lucky that you did you
got this car or whatever and it's like
[ __ ] it was hard work it's a lot more
amplified now that we have social media
oh yeah that's like sometimes I just
thought this 22-year old [ __ ] has a
Bentley but then the grass is really
she's [ __ ] dudes for money and she
had to eat Dookie yeah so I'm like maybe
I don't want that self-awareness I
thought it was just like progression of
life but it's not because that takes
that effort - and everyone's stuck in a
one day thing like all one day I'll work
on myself or I'll work on this but like
self awareness can happen in any age but
for the majority people just doesn't
even happen they don't you put the
effort in to try to figure out their own
[ __ ] brain and that's I add yes I'm
yeah number five did social media for a
week I mean that supera that should be
healthy for everyone yeah yeah I think
we all took a break down a pretty time I
took a cruise last summer with Jacob and
a wife I was like one it wasn't working
in twos like a hundred bucks for like
twelve hours and it was hella slow [ __ ]
that didn't I'm just doing my stuff away
did you did you catch yourself pulling
your phone out stealing one I left I
left in my room how smart and I want to
kill myself
oh great I feel great I feel good number
six is what Joe was talking about which
is like be grateful for the now like
realized that you have powers to do like
change things right now this moment you
don't have to like hope and dream
because there are ways for you to change
your situation right now whether you
might not think so
number seven is take the leap as soon as
possible just do it you know what's
funny is like all these things it's
pretty obvious because most people
aren't that [ __ ] stupid it's like for
example it's like if you want to lose
weight right everyone knows everyone
knows go to the gym eat healthy
know it I don't know any idiot that
doesn't know attack me thank you you
know that really that's what I'm saying
is most people know it no but no one is
really addressing the root of most
issues which is a lot of there's like a
like like an epidemic of like just
mental issues that are going on with
social media with a lot and and people
living for others so I think that's one
of the hugest problems that that were
really dealing with because if you are
in a good mind state like if you feel
positive supported all that all these
things are easy and they come natural
like when you're feeling good about
yourself you want to go and and and get
out there in the world and take the
world on right but if you're pissed or
sad and you're in this mind state like
the first thing you want to do is not
hey let me do something positive let me
it's like just stop doing it like that's
these are stupid-ass solutions just talk
to me directly next time you're going if
you're going through this this list will
not help you like it's just like done
and you know like everybody knows it's
like hey stop being jealous man yeah duh
but that doesn't that doesn't help
anybody would be helpful then I think
you got to do some real [ __ ]
soul-searching and and figure out what
it is that you really want and also
there's a lot of basic things that we
are pulling away from being human and
some sometimes depression and things
come from a physiological or just
lifestyle that people don't understand
like for example like just regular water
sleep and going out getting Sun and and
being with social like people
face-to-face hanging out with people all
these things so like a lot of us hang
out in the room a lot isolated and then
like I'm not just talking about you okay
but then a lot of let's do this right
let's do this we stay on social media
for six hours straight we don't interact
with human beings and then we go [ __ ]
man I don't know why I'm so stressed out
well because we evolved this way where
we absolutely need to talk and see
people's faces get their energy fun like
get sunlight drink water all this stuff
this is natural and then like you know
we're supposed to wake up and sleep with
the Sun like nature and that [ __ ] with
your mind and it [ __ ] with who you are
and people don't address it they go oh
oh it's because you know some other
external thing like it's because
something is happening to me mentally
not do it if you're isolated in the
house and you're thinking all day by
yourself for four hours straight or more
yeah it's gonna [ __ ] with your mind
yeah I'm like in jail personally to me
it is very important because I remember
I was living at this place where the the
windows cannas law and there was no
sunlight I was like [ __ ] I'm so
depressed and I have no idea why do you
stay with us at Casey now we fought so
much on our previous place and that's
cause like half of the house didn't have
any sunlight because of our windows and
they were so small and then we moved to
this new place where you get way more
natural sunlight we're like way happier
I mean we saw the problems but but it's
crazy how small things like that can
actually affect your well-being but but
it's the lifestyle and how we are today
and how disconnected we are from being a
human being it's causing a lot of mental
issues and people don't attribute it to
that they try to figure it out and go
well you know it's like you're trying to
tackle a problem through logic when it
should just be dealt with like nature
and emotions and stuff like that but I
think that's one of the biggest things
that we probably want to deal with
because these lists and stuff I think
most people aren't stupid and they know
[Music]
[Music]